[Music]
hey so today was pretty intense
you'll be catching the shooter i know
it's a great story i just hope pitt can
get in good enough shape to play me in
the movie you know hmm
yeah um also something else happened
i thought i might be pregnant really
yeah
i'm not i got my period and i took a
pregnancy test but it didn't work
because i drank 11 gallons of water i
told you water is bad for you that's not
the takeaway you're absolutely right how
are you how do you feel are you okay i
mean i was really stressed
this wasn't our plan and we agreed we'd
wait a year and
there's so much to do first and it would
have been crazy
right yeah it would have been okay
but also might have been
kind of cool honestly
i was secretly bummed when the test came
back negative
should we just start trying seriously
yeah seriously okay
[Music]
hey did you get my sexy calendar invite
you mean the one titled
8pm coitus yes and the one titled 755
foreplay you didn't accept either invite
oh i can start foreplay later no no i
love foreplay as you know it's just this
is all feeling a little
over scheduled you know it might be
taking some of the fun out of making a
baby
oh okay um so what are you suggesting
maybe we try this
the jake way eating dinner starting with
dessert well that's one jake way you
know the jake way is a brand it
encompasses a whole lifestyle so get
ready
because this month we're making a baby
the jake way
okay i'm in sounds fun so are we doing
it tonight or no no no the jquery does
not believe in scheduling
you gotta just let go you don't know
what the jquery is no but we've got a
name for it and that's a great start
to jake way well i don't want to take
all the credit but i'm pretty sure doing
it the jake way worked
and we're getting pregnant that would be
incredible but
feels like you're setting us up for
disappointment no
i'm just being optimistic you're amazing
we're
amazing and it definitely worked didn't
work ah i knew it i got bumnards
jake right gotta stay optimistic we can
do this
[Music]
so how you feeling well i'm pretty
bummed but amy
could you open your mouth for me what no
forget it i just saw
she's got all her teeth even the back
ones did that turn your mood around
nope but it's okay i figured out how
we're gonna get pregnant by doubling
down on the jake way ooh do you think we
could rent the phone booth from the
movie phone booth no from now on
we're gonna do it the amy way does that
mean we're going back to the overly
scheduled sex thing
no we're gonna go way more scheduled ah
so even less fun big time
this is a test and we're failing because
we're not studying hard enough
or maybe this is just one of those tests
that you can't study for
[Laughter]
wow that's a new laugh this is our
pregnancy war room on the master
calendar we will track ovulation windows
menstruation cycles and
every uterine deposit uterine deposit is
that what we're calling sex now it seems
a little clinical well you could always
shorten it to
ud or ed yeah i don't want to do that
here's a list of everything you cannot
eat while we're trying to conceive
no more nachos even if they're in a
novelty baseball helmet no
whoa this is serious we will adhere to a
strict exercise regimen and sleep
schedule also
no more video games because they cause
stress and they raise your heart rate
more stress than being a police officer
jake i've seen you play mario party
wario cheats
i'm just saying about wario jesus stupid
game look
i know it isn't easy but this could
increase our chances of getting pregnant
by 19
yeah of course absolutely so how do we
get it started dim the lights put on
some music
swallow 35 vitamins each oh cheers
oh let's make a baby
i probably should have had some water
ready well that was definitely
technically sex yep
maybe that was the one nope not the one
i'm so exhausted me too but the doctor
said that it could take a while
i know it's just we're doing everything
right and it's still not working what
kind of perfect person do you have to be
to get pregnant
we're having a baby oh
what in hell why is it so easy for
everyone else to get pregnant
wait look at these stupid guinea pigs
they made 600 babies and we can't make
one
why can't we make 600 babies you can't
compare yourself to guinea pigs babe
you taught me that i'm exhausted and the
universe keeps telling us that it
doesn't want us to have a baby the
message couldn't be clearer so
i'm done like done for this month
done just done
so listen i've been thinking about what
you said this morning
and it has been a really hard couple of
months i'm sorry i'm bad at making
babies
hey hey don't say that it's not your
fault and look
for all we know i could have don't say
you have bum nuts
i wasn't gonna but i think maybe it's
just a thing we can't control that is my
least favorite kind of thing
i know i really wanted to start a family
amy we are a family
you and me so you know we can keep
trying
or look into ivf or adoption or
if we want we can forget about the whole
thing but if we're together i'm happy
ah mario why are you like this hey
so i don't know if you noticed but ever
since i started those hormone treatments
i didn't notice anything
you said that way too quick i mean you
did cry at that one car commercial
and it wasn't even an emotional one it
was about towing capacity yeah
well i called the doctor to see if that
was a common side effect
and apparently it isn't oh no
is everything okay yeah she did have one
guess as to what might be causing it
and um she was right
abs are we having a baby
we're having a baby
it happened i'm pregnant
we're pregnant
what the hell i thought you guys would
be more excited than that charles you
didn't even faint i'm so sorry i'll try
it's not working somebody took me on it
rosa sorry we're so happy for you but we
also
maybe kind of already knew i mean you
didn't do the best job of hiding it
why have you been carrying that box
around so much i just love this box
why are you reading that newspaper it's
two days old i just love this issue
hey why are you wearing that hazmat suit
i just love this look
okay fine so you all knew we were
pregnant good for you but i bet you
didn't figure out that we're having
twins no not really it's one baby i just
needed to see charles faint wait
wait stop the power's back oh yuck
none of you are cute with the lights
fully on you want to play mean girl
kayla
two could play at that game let's talk
about your bangs charles not now i'm
calling amy
jake hey ames look i'm so sorry we're
not there yet but a guy fell down the
stairs and then the old lady shot our
perp and then we stopped a bank robbery
and i lost my shoes and kayla lost her
shoe but we're almost to the hospital
are you there yet what room are you in
the break room what why there isn't
enough time i have to have the baby here
but me and my crazy crew make it to the
hospital that's our birth story oh screw
your bird story just get here
you're giving birth at the precinct is
that safe it's gonna be okay there's a
bunch of firefighters here
right and they're basically just
glorified emts that live together and
sleep in bunk beds
jay she's gonna be okay i just don't
think she can talk right now okay just
tell her that i love her and i'll get
there as fast as i can
[Applause]
i can see the head rosa get over here
i'm going to need a second set of hands
no no she really doesn't want to be down
at that end
no it's okay i got this i can close my
eyes right keep them open oh
damn it just keep pushing you're almost
there no but jake's not here yet
i'm here oh jake i can't believe i made
it i'm gonna see the birth of my oh
we're on page 53. babe we're on page 53.
dino
i wrote a horse
well we did it ames
we made the world's hottest baby say
cute jake
nope this kid is liquid fire
crazy to think in just 17 short years
he's gonna be six foot seven in the
number one draft pick for the knicks
hmm and then he's gonna pass up that
opportunity to pursue his true passion
library sciences well the important
thing is we'll support him no matter
what
even if he's a huge huge nerd especially
then
are we gonna be okay at this i mean this
entire day felt like a warning from the
universe
i almost missed the birth we had our
baby at the precinct a firefighter
touched our child
we washed him off yeah but i'll always
know babe we talked about this
everyone balances working kids yeah but
everyone's not a cop
true but when our son wants to hear
about the day he was born
we get to tell him that his dad helped a
bunch of people
and foiled a bank robbery
i guess that is kind of cool and his mom
managed a
city-wide emergency while actually
giving birth
i'm proud for her son to have you as a
dad
me too for you to be the mom
i was just agreeing with the nice thing
you said about me i love you
you